يقدر عدد مسيحي الاردن بمئتين وتسعه
وثلاثين الفرد بحسب احصائيه صدرت عام 2015
من المعهد الملكي للدراسات الدينيه اي ما
يعادل اكثر من اثنين في المئه من عدد
السكان
تنقسم الطوائف المسيحيه في الاردن الى
الروم الارثوذكس واللتين والكاثوليك
والبروتستانت مشاكل الناس اللي بيعانوا
منها قاعدين عائلات كثيره
وما في صدى كان بالماضي لكن الان استطعنا
الحمد لله ان نضع هذا على الطاوله ونضع
امام المسؤولين ونضع امام مجلس النواب
ومجلس الاعيان
ان يصبح هذا الموضوع موضوع نقاش وهو
المطلوب الان ان يصبح موضوع نقاش يصار
فيما بعد الى اصدار تعليمات او قانون او
نظام خاص فيما يخص الارث وفيما يخص
المحاكم الكنسيه لتتبعوا الى ان الوصول
الى انه العدل والمساواه بين جميع افراد
المجتمع الاردني هلا
التعديلات المن طالبها انه البنت تحجب
الارث بمعنى انه اللي عنده بنات بناته
بدخلش اطراف اخرى على على الارث وبياخذوا
حصصهم ويصبعهم ولاجئين في بيوتهم بدفعوا
اجر
الصحيح انه احنا عم نعاني من موضوع الارث
انا بشكل شخصي كونه عندي ثلاث بنات
عم بعاني بموضوع الارث حاولنا جهدنا انه
القانون الحالي الموجود هو ما بينصفنا
حاولنا مع عده جهات وعده امور لنوصل لحل
ما في حل الا انه نسجل مباشره باسامي
البنات وهذا اللي عم نحاول نعمله وعملنا
جزء منيح منه وعم نكمل بالباقي بس
بالنهايه هذا مش حل مش حل نهائي لكل
العائلات نحن بنوضح للبنات كل التفاصيل
اللي ممكن يتعرضوا لها حتى يعني بحكي لهم
يعني اذا صار اشي الي ولا ولا لابوكم
ممنوع توقعوا على اي ورقه بدون ما انتم
تكونوا حامين حالكم يعني لو وجود محامي
اذا انتم مش عارفين بتجيبوا محامي او
بتستعينوا بحدا
بخوالكم بعمكم المهم ما بتوقعوا على اي
اشي الا يكون بناء على تفاصيل معينه انكم
تقدروا توقعوا عليها المعطل الاساسي هو
الفكر العشائري وانا بقول للاخوان كلهم
لما بناقشهم في هذا الموضوع بقول له انت
لما بتعطي بتعطي بنتك مش جوز بنتك فيجب
هذا هذا المفهوم ان يكون في عقلك انه انا
لما بعطي بنتي يعني لما بنتك بتكون عندك
في البيت ما هي بتكون معززه مكرمه ليش لما
بتطلع من البيت وتبطل معزز مكرمه بطل انت
بدك تعطي اخوها